so this class is analyzed this so please
don't sue us robert de niro although
based on your acting performances lately
we're going to sue you okay so this is
the game Jacob with two seas versus
Peter and we're with two N's
so the solid yeah and this was played
today
well then you put the wrong date on it
tastes 22nd so I'm not going to look at
it okay the next game yeah okay so this
was La défense Francaise which is very
important as MV Elle's coming to st.
Louis the French defense okay I've seen
in everybody's favorite game Fisher
Feingold what year was it ah you're so
close but you went over yeah I was
thinking Arby's 1963 for those of you at
home who hear people going I don't think
this move that's good eating popcorn
okay so night two d2x clam raise your
hand what variation of the French is
this you right
named after very good and what country
was he from maybe did hungry exist then
what what you what's the answer
no nobody knows no they won the World
Cup there you go
okay so Knight f6 that's a common move
you can also do like ten other moves
that's probably the most common move now
in the 70s when corn was black here he
played c5 and people take on e4 now also
okay e5 is common this says Knight to d7
was it this one in this class you never
know okay
Knight F to d7 would be the proper
notation and now everybody's Bishop is
bad so it's sort of like Everybody Loves
Raymond which is also bad but this
bishops are bad so this position up on C
it's very suspicious
there's your bun c1 is blocked so off
and white later wants to play f4 to
bolster his Center so instead of playing
Knight f3 sometimes they play 92 the
other reason is this Knight goes to f3
so our Bishop on c1 can get out but if
we play Knight f3 and put the other half
3 is hard so 92 would block the bishop
on e and F 1 so Bishop g3 is normally
played and was played here and this is
all normal and then 92 so this is like a
main theoretical line now black has a
couple ways of playing and then there's
the third way that was actually played
so that's yeah
black can just do nothing like Bishop e7
castle or black can get aggressive and
play f6 and attack the center so black
sort of mixed his metaphors okay it's
all this simile to me
taketake Bishop e7 well normally we
don't take right away and do that
because then I could go to c3 later and
or g3 which is illegal okay
and when we do take sometimes we play
Queen b6 and we attack the pawn and we
play f6 and attack that pawn because
this bishop is very suspicious if I knew
how to push these things yeah there we
go yeah that Bishop is envious of the
other pieces so it's in red okay it's
not scared so it's not in yellow okay I
do how to do it okay so Bishop e7
everybody castles okay good and now most
people would play Knight f3 here and
then get the bishop on c1 out but white
flight a3 which is another idea now
Knight b4 is risky and white might play
B for Bishop b2
okay and now f6 okay and when black
plays have six there's a move that white
likes to play here although it looks
like you probably can't play maybe which
is Knight f4 because you want to take on
e6 which is good and what would black do
in this position
who I take everything when I play chess
so I would take something I would take
this guy defending my pawn and
destroying white centre there's actually
a variation where this happens when
blacks King is on e 8 it white plays
Queen h5 check and everybody cries
because too complicated but since black
already Castle I don't know about that
so after f6 Y could play f4 probably 9
f3 just hangs upon so he took taking is
reasonable and normally they play Knight
takes and the black Bishop is on d6 but
here he took with the Bishop which
attacks the pawn so Knight f3
now black made a very unusual move I was
trying to figure out why he made it and
then he showed me why he made a next
move so there you go
white played black played work f7 a not
often seen moving this variation and he
wanted to play Knight f8 because the
night wasn't passive enough so you want
to make it more passive okay well the
problem is White's pieces have a lot of
scope and a lot of places to go and
blacks Bishop on C it isn't very good
work any it's not very good if the
knight goes to FA that's not very
aggressive so white just has a nice
position Queen c2 which I guess
threatens h7 so black defended it nice
and then B for the point of a3 rooks e7
I never saw Burke f7 to c7 in this
opening so I guess you learn something
new every day
ok now black wants to do a discovered
attack I mean I would probably move my
queen anywhere but where he moved it no
he's scary where he moved it moved it to
be to I don't like that because it's on
the same diagonal so that seems risky to
me
ok Queen b2 b6 not sure why you played
that you will explain
well you want your Bishop on d7 not be
seven because then you're east six pawn
is defended and later in the game you
may want to play Bishop PA Bishop g6 or
Bishop h5 like here's not much of a
future but okay g6 to trade off his
great Bishop h5 to teach him a lesson so
this is probably better and it saves a
tempo to move your Bishop in one move
instead of b6 first
okay so Bishop f4 I understand that move
although he didn't play it okay then
rook f7 interesting bishop g3 solid and
now a6
that's a lot of pawn moves and then you
do what I said you would do you played
rips you played rook to Bishop to d7
yeah yeah black doesn't have a lot of
active play here Black's sort of sitting
around okay I like what white did
doubled works on this e-file good b5
giving away the c5 square very risky
rook c8 and now the bishop found a home
on d6 and c5 I assume yeah this looks
like not so much fun for black are you
having fun now
that's so much fun King h8 and now white
got very aggressive and played a four
following one of my rules which rules
that play for that you've been in my
class before yeah now b5 s attacked and
a6 and so forth yeah I don't know what
black should do here I just yelled at
one of my students for making this move
then you made it it was like an hour ago
outside
Knight a seven I said don't ever play
987 that ain't where the night goes well
hopefully white played a collinear move
here because those are really cool who
was white are you in the room you you
have to season your name yeah okay yeah
maybe it was like a stutter yeah okay
you didn't play the colinear move what
is it yeah rook c7 it goes towards
Israel it doesn't take it haha that
showed him then you threaten the knight
on a seven but you played another mean
move 95
it's also pretty mean and then I yelled
at my student to do the same thing same
game yeah he he had a dark squared
bishop he put all his buns on white
squares then he traded off for a night
he didn't do well yeah yeah well your
works trapped so I don't I blame you
less but yeah like when you trade off
this bishop then this is the bishop you
have left with then yeah he took with
the bishop I would have taken with a
pawn and played 94 but that's me knight
c6 I like Bishop d7 ex clam man I didn't
see Bishop g7 d6 okay because Bishop d7
ex clam Bishop d6 yeah Bishop ei8
attacking the bishop but he saw it that
was your last plan okay ninety-seven
defending his beep on collinear move
rook c5 good takes Bishop a6 that pass
be pawn looks stronger than the past a
pawn bishop c7 and what a bishop moves
this should be five hmm I don't like
blacks position so much I like it a
little can't black take the bishop on b5
and get a Brooke at a piece for a queen
and then whites winning what it's close
you have to take this and then he takes
back and then you take back
I've won worse positions like everyday I
guess everybody like who does Bill
Thompson I do
he had meetin two against me check me
and I still won on the board too he
played it not he didn't play it yeah so
so yeah you made a slight mistake here
ah
you played Knight c6x clam but not X
clam
yeah and then he took and then you
resigned I mean I don't know if you
resigned but he's not keeping score yeah
but that wasn't fun like black didn't
have any fun there so like in this
position I think you want to play
instead of playing Bishop e7 castles
giving white time to build you want to
you know Queen b6 and f6 and attack the
center really fast yeah this should be
seven and castles is slow and I think
you don't want to play Bishop takes I
think you want to take with a night and
then then play your Bishop to d6 your
other Bishop to d7 and your Knights sort
of good on f6 because your knight on g7
wasn't so good then you played Knight f8
where it was less good so yeah then it
just seemed like white was like you know
had everything yeah and then you played
rook c7 or cap 7 yeah cuz Bishop f4 is
coming that's what you want the knight
on f6 and play the bishop on d6 and even
here maybe you should play like you
always play Queen b6 in the friends
because you want to take on d4 because
he has an isolated D pawn so you could
take it that'll show him but you never
really attacked it after you apply
Bishop f6 T defendant you sort of gave
up on attacking it but okay you could
try to keep attacking this and get
counter play and then yeah then things
didn't work out well
yeah b6 isn't good and okay black just
really passive here alright now look at
a more fun game it's a game I played
gray and I played it today but I wrote
the date down right you know how I wrote
it down right is anybody know how I
yelled what's the date to my cover and
he told me that's yeah that's how I knew
yeah okay yeah okay so so this is my
game with Mario and then let's see we
okay
d5 now who's the third highest rated
player in the world
Caruana
and mario followed my game with cara
wanna she doesn't make any sense but
here Fabiana made like the losing move
he played Knight f6 that's what Fabio
did against me who he was about 2200
okay so when you see him the next month
say hey didn't find go beat you this way
and then he'll say yeah what I did play
CD yeah yeah yeah you don't want to play
Knight f6 here you want to defend your
pawn with a pawn C 6 or 6 or you could
do some other crazy moves like I do but
95 6 gives the center away now in this
position against Fabiano I played Knight
f3 because that's the best move and then
I beat them like you know whatever some
good analogy
ok there was it a metaphor anyway I get
sorry I played efore now in this
position efore is considered not the
best because well I can play Knight f6
and then I if I defend my pawn Black has
one good move here who can find it who
yeah II five X clam and black wins no I
mean it's equal yeah and the problem is
if I take a free pawn it's not so free
because if Knight takes the knight takes
e4 and if King takes he Forks my e put
my my two pawns here so e5 is considered
ok for black ok but Mario played Knight
b6 now there's less pressure on my
center so I can start developing pieces
and such Knight c3 X clam
now e6 is not so good because the bishop
is sort of sad reminds you of your game
right yeah ok and I played Knight f3 and
he didn't pin my knight because it's
illegal so he played bishop in this
Knight the problem is since white since
black put his pawns of the center on
white squares specifically these pawns
here are blocking his white squared
bishop and his other bishop has a lot of
squares he doesn't want to trade his
bishop for my knight although he did I
attacked his Queen
but he saw it which I bet I lost to
Spencer now so Queen d7 not the best
square for the Queen look here now when
you have like greater force and furious
anger that's a movie then you you you
don't sue me Sam Jackson your beer is
great okay so you have to develop your
you have more pieces developed and then
you can attack when you have no pieces
develop then you can't attack you got to
get your pieces developed now in this
position these pieces haven't moved yet
so blacks kinda like castle and get his
night out then he can attack but he
attacked anyway okay now your typical
player in this room would blunder their
queen so that mario would beat you right
like you for example sir you would play
Queen a for winning a night and that
today you go like ah I didn't see that
okay and then I would lose because my
knight spend and if Robert Hess was here
he would complain that it's making this
weird noise although it's not making
that noise you remember that from three
years ago okay what yeah okay so I
didn't give my Queen away instead I
decided winning was better now
I wanted to play Bishop to b5 but then
he takes it so I didn't do that
but if he didn't take it that would be
good right
so I played Knight e5 and now if his
Queen moves I'll play Bishop b5 check or
Queen takes Knight Chuck so it looks
good for me yeah see how his Queens
attacked okay now he missed his last
chance if he'd played the right move I
would have been really confused but he
made a mistake and then I was less
confused right move is Knight takes b2
with total confusion because if I play
the obvious Queen b3 for example
threatening seven of his pieces
he plays Queen takes d4 with confusion
okay so I don't know so this I was
thinking about going to Queen d2 here
and now his Queens attacked at his
Knights attacked so probably good for me
but computer might say I'm lost I don't
know
but that was the last chance probably
still good for a Wyatt instead he took
this yeah you can't ever do that
you can't pin a knight with the bishop
and then trade them because the knight
can't move and his Knight was attacking
my b2 pawn but now I don't have a b2
pawn so it's not attacking it so now his
Queens attacked and if he moves it I'll
take his Knight on a4 so he played the
only move to save material which was
sort of like the horizon effect right he
would have said that right yeah okay if
you knew computer chess of the 70s you
know what I'm talking about right you
know what if you were then you were
there when it first started yeah okay so
he played nights of b2 and now if I take
his queen he takes my queen yeah so I
moved here now he made a slight error
and that was a slight misunderstand okay
now he has to lose a piece so he should
move his Queen and lose his knight but
he went all-in okay and unfortunately
was it like meta Saul and so it was like
drug-induced or something
so don't sue me like mantis now you're
on drugs okay so Queen a4 all in and now
I played the boob that was very strong
raise your hand if you know you
incorrect what Bishop e5 check with a
slight advantage yeah so yeah his King
you made a lot of Queen moves and a lot
of Knight moves and these other pieces
didn't move so that was risky okay you
got to move your Queen side okay and
then I was sort of better at the some
point okay
and he forked my Bishop at night so I
almost resigned but I found this one
and if he takes my night Queen g7 meat
is good
so he didn't take my night he played FG
notice how I stopped him from castling
right now my queen and Knight are pretty
active my rooks are not pretty active so
I played h4 put it in H now my rook on
h1 is going to do good you may not think
so but just wait okay so he played
ninety seven to trade nights I thought
and I took and how he surprised me I
thought he would play Knight takes
Knight but I was wrong I've been wrong
before he played a 5x clam okay that's
not the best now I played the most
incisive move threatening his rook and
debate who can figure it out
who I ask who you 9 g 6x clam
now I'm threatening me with advantage
and I'm threatening his rook
so I expected pawn takes Knight rook
takes rook check and then I thought I
was doing pretty well okay then he could
castle with my rook through check okay
so well that was my analysis so he
played c5 stopping Queen e7 mate so I
took okay
and I promoted to a knight and then B 6
to get his Bishop out solid ok and then
I started taking stuff Merc h7 Bishop
out and now guess what black played the
answer is funny
castles yeah finally yeah that's safe
yeah ok attacking my night when he
canceled that looks at my score she to
see if he was legal and I was like yeah
ok so night night f7 now he made a
slight mistake if otherwise he'd be ok
riki 8 and in real life and in chest
never walk into a fork real life is
worse yeah now all his pieces are
attacked which is it easy
so ok he played here and I took that I
think
oh no I'm wrong as usual he played king
c7 then I took what check then he played
here think and I took this okay and then
here now what piece do I want near his
King Queen so I played you have a queen
b3 is a white screen is a white square
bishop I would never play such a risky
move
so Queen B - ah safe safe right in fact
is Laurence Olivier and he asked Dustin
Hoffman in turn and it turned out it was
safe nobody well you would home got it
okay so he played Kings see it attacking
my rook but I saw it and then I took
this and what would the computer do here
incorrect computers are resigned
incorrect that hangs me to one incorrect
that hangs baton one Bishop b7x clam I
don't think I have Maine tonight to
Bishop d7 I think there should be 7s the
only who does that main one so I think
that was the cause I stick and during
the game what a computer do but he took
setting up for the next game the Kings
on e8 and then may it yeah and I learned
this mate in chess camp this week Queen
and rook yeah so yeah he didn't develop
too much I guess the Queen side I moved
21 I like that so I gained one rating
point ray well I know there was a game
played outside and the 95-degree heat
has a good idea smart between the two
smartest members of the Chess Club GM
Hall and non-gm Flint the second-worst
Flint I know Flint Michigan okay so d4x
clam Justin's White Knight f6 X clam
then it's some scribbling okay Knight c3
and now he wanted to play the black bar
dealer but in bad fashion so instead of
E for right away he played f3 breaking a
very
and rule never play f3 I wonder who won
this game so some people like to play
gambits because they don't like having
pieces those are my kind of opponents
okay but ke4 doesn't lose a pawn now so
you prevented e4 with Bishop f5 then you
played Bishop g5 now it's like a rouser
varus Viktor veresov well by
transposition maybe okay now went 9b d7
and you went all tactical autumn he made
the most tactical move ever Knight takes
d5 very subtle so the idea is if black
takes it which he did then white plays
d4 which was played okay
and now black attack the bishop so white
should move the bishop away and he did
if you lose it here then Knight e3 is
risky so he played Bishop to d2 and now
he five complicated yeah so blacks a
piece up and White's going to get it
back but White's pieces aren't developed
so much so I don't know still theory
okay II takes bishop is that what it
says that's good notation
he takes retakes owl that's even better
what will do I live in so if you want to
keep fishing correctly your IE takes f5
he takes el okay so what's this German
either one is it the whole game it's
either one well that's the way it is so
Swedes and Germans keep score the same
now I understand
so do you tell sweet if you will the
keeping score in German show that yeah
okay so II takes d4 who's better here
and why discuss oh you like black also
so what would you do differently
I think I wouldn't yeah that's that was
you only developed peace you got rid of
it that way your other pieces could be
on the first rank okay okay so then
you've checked blocking your Bishop on
f1 and your knight on G one making sure
you couldn't develop anything but you
checked him so you know for two
significant his vision about yeah he got
his Bishop out no okay then you castled
and so does your opponent and g4 okay
attacking yeah when you got a piece on
the first ring now some move was played
Bishop g5 alright that's a move so White
has all his pawns on white squares
therefore though not defending the dark
squares too much because they're on
white squares then when you trade off
the dark square Bishop C goes into E 3
and B 4 and F 4 and G 5 and you're sort
of not developed too much so Bishop g5 I
like you moved your queen again because
you wanted to get your Bishop out
eventually and he played here and you
again not developing any pieces that's
not your style
f4 and now I think it's this Knight c5
which is what you expected Knight c5
looks pretty good defends your D pawn
attacks the Queen the Queen has to stay
on f4 so here now it says like F takes T
what OS takes T alright so s takes T
then you took on g5 ok complicated then
he went back yeah yeah so you're down
the exchange and you have no development
but your pawns are scary-looking were
you scared no yeah I know what you mean
so you had one minor piece developed so
you traded that off ok now you got all
your pieces yeah then you took this pawn
so you get another tempo now he's
threatening rook e1 mate so you stopped
it here
yeah okay then he took man what a typo
Wow he put a really good movie er other
than you two what's your black do here
although actually every move wins but
his one was probably the best oh well
maybe not probably anyone ya wrote kg8
is really good too but he played 94
which might be better because 9f2 is
annoying you know what I mean yeah well
I mean 9f2 if your King goes away from
f2 if your king goes towards f2 a knight
g3 discovered check is good that's an
interesting final position your
developments a little iffy little yeah
resigns good because you're going to
lose your rook so if the King goes to
the left
Beyonce style then Knight f2 wins the
rook the King goes to the right to
defend this square Knight g3 check wins
the rook
so resigning was well-timed yeah good
job good reason regret Ignatian so what
about if you don't play Queen d2 and you
play like cool man yeah how's it play
Queen f2 but then everything wins 94
Queen g5 check and if it's his movie and
hey you force pretty good yeah you
should get your bishops and nights out
while you were hot the heat you couldn't
take it yeah okay so you can't go in
that room in the corner because if you
can't stand the heat stay out of the
kitchen huh yeah is there enough popcorn
left could we feed everybody watching on
YouTube the next like six months yeah
okay and then the last game is all win
versus Ryan Ryan works here and he lost
this is like your third tournament game
ever yeah who was your second against me
yeah yeah so Owen who's you know
sometimes kicked out of the club but not
always so he was allowed in the club so
I got to play yeah there we go
okay yeah c4 c5 what's this called the
British we had a long discussion today
about the difference between the UK and
Great Britain no neither ones okay but
okay and as most of you know I was
married in England as you know my first
wedding and at the reception was the
former Prime Minister of England pretty
good that he didn't see that coming now
and it was the Prime Minister before
Margaret Thatcher right before Margaret
Thatcher they may know that was like
nope
prime minister yeah
Callaghan and Callaghan died about a
year or two ago so but he was still
alive as far as I know with the British
so it's hard to tell okay so d3x glam
what alright that's legal 9c3 does he
still play instantly every move yeah
yeah that's how he rolls yeah okay g3
defy these those are pretty good now you
remember blacks this is blacks third
tournament game so I'll give him a break
III well without e3 is a little passive
I don't know I don't like III okay
knight Knight f6 it looks like the
whites playing its third tournament game
yeah 92 you want to write night ge2 when
both Knights can go
you have to denote which Knight is your
score well it has to be because I can't
they're like every goin score yeah so
the other night could also go to e2 yeah
okay Bishop e7 Castle this says you long
castle but I don't believe it yeah so
okay Knight f4 that's pretty good move
Knight f4 shocking yeah now you play a
move I wouldn't have considered yeah so
here you either have to let them take
your bishop or play Bishop g4 those are
your options okay but these are moves
that beginners play a lot then they stop
playing them although not them
but most people okay you played night b4
to defend your pawn but that's not a
stable square and horses like to be
stable you see what I'm saying there you
could yeah okay
so that night can easily be kicked out
okay
sort of like Owen also easily kicked out
okay which he has been so a3 that you
were shocked by that yeah and now you
won't do it anymore
yeah now there's an opening called the
Slav which you all play and then the
Slav blacks trying to play B five
winning upon and why it's like nope a
four then you can't play b5 and when
white plays a for black often puts a
piece on b4 because the pawn can go back
to a 3 but when then one's on a 2 then
you can't go to b4 because they just
kick you away yeah so now you learn that
so if this pawns over here then you know
you can go to be forward immunity okay
so a 3 in the new back Queen b3 that's
not seen but we're smoother than that ok
now you've got two pawns attacked I
guess you could play Knight a5 that
probably save upon well then I could
play c4 which is usually explosive c4
nothing okay good okay as long as one of
you gets it yeah 1985 you probably lose
upon probably so you lost upon with
Queen d7 defending your pawn were you
shocked he took on d5 yeah shocking
doesn't say which night so I have to
guess this one okay I guess then lots of
captures were made takes
takes and you played nothing suggested
night a five and he played this
suggested Queen a to who now there was
more taking the like got confused and I
mixed my metaphors here so Knight takes
d5 oh he played Bishop takes d5 then
nine a five and then there was some
taking here and this looks like
black-white Sepang a head now you made a
slight mistake that was another slight
understatement what's white threatening
with Chuck so maybe you should do
something by that so did you see your
Bishop was hanging but didn't see it was
check or didn't see it was hanging that
sort of answered my question yeah
alright that when he took he were like
wait a minute I want that back yeah so
he played Knight b3 attacking the rook
but then the bishops hanging the check
so yeah that's not so good now usually
you don't want to improve your
opponent's pieces the knight on d5 is
really good because that's on d5 the
Queen on d5 you can harass so you should
just move your queen somewhere or play
rook da rim G it makes a lot of sense
because if he trades Queens is deep
one's a little tender you could take it
next move his knight can't go here and
you can come here later and your rook on
a 8 isn't winning any awards
Rickon dietas was better so Queen takes
Queen not a good move yeah
Rick Rick d8 spatter or just Queen
somewhere else and then play rugby in
attack is Queen but yeah now your make
it is not good and then you made this
Knight really good because you let him
take a free piece and you play King h8
oh this is king h1 and then he moved his
rook I guess where I don't know 8 - wow
that's not where I would have moved it
ok then you attacked his knight or you
play that and he saw it or he didn't
hard to read the score and then you put
your work here so your game is great if
you weren't down a piece it looks good
now but yeah but no piece g6 he saw it
that move smells a little NH for anyone
no yeah thank you okay then rook d6 what
do you think here did you think you were
like okay or that you're losing is you
down if he's yeah down to pieces and
good but still fight because you're
playing all what you moves instantly so
you always have a chance never play f6
okay d4 DSU in this rook Bishop to d2 b6
is solid well if it's good but it's
solid a4 now your Knights are going to
be for you played a 4 a 4 takes Bishop
b4 oh and plays the most complicated way
uh puppies that it looks like it's okay
though
work d5e d4 and you got your pont you go
on up we won upon but you're down apiece
unfortunate this would makes no sense by
bishops III that was bishops on well
strapped it's trying
wow he trapped his bishop wow that was
amazing how did he do it he's talented
luckily he has rook luckily he has
rookie three otherwise it's loosing his
bishop that's pretty funny yeah now the
bishop can move anywhere that was genius
work a3 but he can defend it
darn then you took another pawn now you
play to move most people wouldn't
consider so in the endgame you want your
king to move up back is bad because your
Kings good in the endgame and you were
worried about rookie seven Shack so you
played King GA but that's you don't
checking on g8 so if Ricky seven check
is a good move you probably want to play
oh wait I was even worse
all you want to play route to d4 to
attack his bishop then if you check so
you play King f8 and all his pieces are
attacked that would be a nice blunder on
his part here then check let's say here
now you're attacking everything rook
takes Bishop Bishop camu cousin Rex
hanging so that rook d4 would be good
but you played here you know which is
Madonna kind of move because it
justifies what he's doing nothing no
need a smarter audience okay now f6 is
sort of weak so he took it so your king
was defending f6 then you undefended it
were you shocked when you went here what
you should be shocked yes is the right
answer if it's no then you shouldn't let
him do it
yeah so now you went back and then
Bishop g8 and they agreed to add rock as
a repetition no that's now this shook c3
d4 that's legal bishop d4 is legal
Bishop c5 is legal turkey 7 Shack you
probably moved your king takes takes you
checked him very good all right Rick b1
I assume yeah d5 I guess it's B Oh H 5 H
4 it's a funny move I like it and you
resigned here yeah yeah
and unlike every other kid I've ever met
since you're not a kid you spell to
design correctly I like the way the kid
spell it they just write nonsense huh
yeah it's funny I gave a chess camp last
week in Ann Arbor at the Gerald Ford
Presidential Library true true story and
because he went to Michigan what did he
do a Michigan he blue football
quarterback yet anyway
I tell the kids never resigned but the
reason we're in this building is because
the president resigned so it's hard to
explain that to them but to finish off
the lecture with a very important
anecdote very important I asked the kids
why was Gerald our Ford the Pres
like they never had an accident never an
afford and the guy said wait a minute I
know this he was the head of the north
and the Civil War at what it ended he
became president that was like what that
was his answer
somehow I beat that kid at chess yeah
somehow yeah that was the best answer I
had to that's when you know things are
tough yeah okay so in some of these
games pieces were staying on the first
row in fact in the last night I gave
earlier today was one of the employees
of the club he's since been fired uh all
his pieces on the back row of the whole
game
he moved pawns every move he's the best
player at the club
so yeah you got it you got to get your
pieces out because when they're staying
on the first row its final position are
on the first row you know but that's
same with Harper so all right so I'll
try to be funnier next time like Tony
Kornheiser and I'll have my Canada flag
yeah and I'll see you guys next time
that please you give me too little
credit please